welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on how you can
catch a case of the big old green
meansies from an infected family member
and i'm not talking about the flu oh no
it's a different kind of green meansies
my name is mt and i'm here today i'm so
happy that my brother tommy bechtold is
back big head gang oh yes
the prison system can't keep me down for
long i'm a free man baby and here we go
yo i was wearing my free my dude tommy
shirts for months you guys can get those
free tommy free my dude tommy shirts
on my website it's on the dark web uh
you know you gotta have a vpn which we
may talk about later or may not i don't
know what the ads are today listen all
the allegations of tommy hacking into
the pentagon are false okay i hacked
into the pentagram which is an s m club
in new york city
based on satanic worship and by the way
it wasn't much on their website just
some links to some nfts so uh
which of course is uh stands for not fun
torture in the old days
so hit me with that big question tommy
you got it baby boy disney plus day gave
us our first look at the new she-hulk
series coming to the streaming platform
next year in the clip we see jennifer
walters interacting with smart hulk in
what looks like it could be the
mysterious
lab that's why they make all their uh
rap albums the gamble
in the gamut lab with a pen and a pad
trying to get this damn green off
because they're stable
i love that white man know all the words
to eminem songs
he's white man jesus of course you do
even though that was the dr dre lyric
all right anyway are they insinuating
that she-hulk got her powers from bruce
banner and all these us this week's big
question which is how exactly are the
hulk's powers transferred to other
people hmm
yep it's totally this is the perfect
opportunity for this question because of
she-hulk i mean that's right she just
got her powers how did she get empowered
can those powers be passed on to other
people well i think it's time to make
like bruce banner and put a scientific
mind to the methodology behind creating
a hulk and as the whole family begins to
grow in the mcu because you know we got
helen cho already in the mcu and she's
amadeus cho's mom so i'm today's show is
coming the comics have shown us many
different versions of the hulk over the
years and as well as a whole group of
people who have the ability to hulk out
oh go
bruce damn poke make tea that's my
favorite is uh english professor hulk i
hope it's chamomile tea because it has
very calming properties
[Laughter]
i'll call teddy bear and go night night
oh put on nightcap hulk hate sleeping
alone since wife died i forgot i forgot
to tell you that english professor hulk
is a grieving widower i mean of course
his husband was tony stark
does
they were science bros
that was his only friend uh closest
competitor anyway but how is hulk able
to share his powers can anyone
potentially become a hulk well let's
take a look at what we know from the
films and the comics and see what we can
you know
figure out hulk stuff you know just a
hulk investigation book hypotheses
well of course let's tackle the gamma
lab that you mentioned tommy because
it's very important in end game when we
first meet smart hulk we learned that
bruce and hulk were able to come to a
truce thanks to 18 months in the gamma
lab and it's there that bruce was able
to mix the brains and lebron to coexist
with his inner mean green machine and
though he never really explains how he
was able to do this we pretty much
assumed that bruce would live out his
days as smart hulk and that was of
course until we saw him in the
post-credits scene in chiang chi and now
we don't really know what's true anymore
like i thought you were supposed to be
green man why are you looking regular
okay i don't care about bruce give me
the green the queen machine or maybe the
post-credit hulk we serve bruce we saw
at the end of shang chi is a skrull and
that's why he looks like that i don't
know did i just do a rogue theory in the
middle of a big question maybe i did
they're both green and you know they're
both transformed no one suspects bruce i
mean bruce is a nice boy he's the nice
guy like no one
no one's gonna expect him to to be a
traitor i mean they might expect him to
destroy everything in his path but not
because he's a traitor right it's too
nice but hey what kind of work was bruce
doing in this gamma lab that led to this
breakthrough like could he have been
trying to stabilize his gamma irradiated
blood to make it safe to transfer to
other people in need because you know
that was sort of what he was doing when
he first was experimenting with gamma in
the first place he wanted to make the
world a better place but then you know
he broke a ton of [ __ ] in um sokovia it
happens and we know that bruce is well
aware of just how volatile his blood is
because in the incredible hulk movie
from 2008 with edward norton who we
don't talk about anymore for some reason
we do not speak his name when bruce is
laying low in south america working in
the bottling plant we saw just how much
he freaked out when just a drop of his
blood spilled into the machinery all
those bottles and that blood does get
drank by stan lee which maybe explains
how he is able to exist in so many mcu
films and speak to the watchers because
he just has a hulked out brain i think
that's how he uh just came up with
spider-man i think it was just a soda
absolutely it's all carbonation and uh
gamma radiation well you know they used
to put cocaine in a lot of sodas too ah
the good old days tommy good old days i
could explain a lot of marvel characters
could have been uh good old-fashioned
original formula coca-cola hard at work
oh man uh the original uh four loko
as well
[Laughter]
shout out to 2010. if you survived that
that's like an eight that's like an
eight loko yeah for sure
but is the scene that we see taking
place in the she-hulk clip with jennifer
walters in the box a glimpse into that
very same gamma lab like it certainly
looks like a lab and hulk does not have
his post-blip arm sling that he you know
had in previous films it's possible that
hulk has finally started to heal from
the injury or this scene could be taking
place in the past before the events of
endgame when banner was spending his 18
months in the gamma lab so if bruce was
able to make his gamma irradiated hulk
blood more stable then it might explain
why jennifer walters is able to maintain
her personality and her serenity when
she is she-hulk but why would bruce be
sharing his hulk blood with jennifer in
the first place well i think it's time
to explain just how to make a hulk are
you ready tomathen yes i am two two let
us hulk out on the whole train yes smash
smash all aboard
here's how to make a hulk because we all
know the story of how the hulk came to
be in the mcu bruce banner was working
on a secret super soldier program under
the orders of thaddeus ross because
after captain america was on the scene
people were like we gotta make more
captain americas and bruce thought he
was you know helping soldiers with
radiation poisoning and when he tried
the serum on himself
with a little dose of gamma radiation
boom we get the hulk everyone's favorite
dopey uh murder machine and that's just
your standard hulk creation story he was
not bitten by a radioactive
pea
um he was or a green bean and that's the
only creation story that we have in our
family is the hulk creation story we're
hulkathists
our bible is the marvel omnibus it's
great
that's my bible too so i think i'm a
hocus but how do you make other hulks
well let's start with his not so good uh
buddy abomination because you know
abomination stabbed him with his spikes
one time and after that they just
weren't very good yeah that's fair
though and of course abomination is emil
blonsky and another person working for
thaddeus ross and i'm starting to think
that this guy is uh no good as a person
this ross fellow he's constantly on the
wrong side he's like oh tony stark is
gone and the planet is needs a heroes
arrest these people um war machine we
need all the best heroes arrested thanks
ross you dumbass so yeah emil bonski was
another person working for thaddeus
rocks in the first hulk film who was
underinformed about exactly what he was
assigned to do and ross wanted blonsky
to track down and kill the hulk but you
know that didn't work he got a nice
visit uh to a tree george george george
of the jungle strong yes he can
[Music]
out for be
he just got launched into it and as a
regular old special ops commander for
the british royal marines he was no
match on his own so blonsky winds up
getting two doses of the recreated super
soldier serum and an injection of the
hult's gamer irradiated blood and boom
you got yourself an abomination an
abomination is not able to transform out
of his monster form like bruce does as
far as we know as a viet maybe he just
likes it maybe just constantly wants to
be strong but has a fully conscious and
able to speak emil blonsky at the helm
so it's sort of like a you know meshing
of the two like we see with a professor
hulk sort of it's possible that these
events may have always been rolling
around in bruce's mind knowing that his
blood can be injected into others for
the purposes of making another hulk so
maybe that's why he worked on his blood
in the gamma lab to make it more
palatable for transfusion and i feel
like this makes a lot of sense because
we do see in falcon in the winter
soldier that there is this need for
super soldier people like you know and
you know vision even even touches on
this in um civil war when he talks about
the introduction of tony stark kind of
changing the world and humanity's sort
of being inspired by the introduction of
these heroes so when tony stark was
introduced uh everyone wanted to make
iron man tech so when captain america
was introduced everyone wanted to make
more captain americas and so at this
point in 2023 2024 i think that we know
we are
going into this huge like we need the
world wants to match the avengers the
world wants you know more quantum energy
the world wants to master gamut like
people just want to be like the avengers
and so uh i do i think this is a really
great time for uh shield but what about
she-hulk like how did she make it to the
hulk family album well in the comics
jennifer walters is the cousin of bruce
banner and she does get shot by a
mobster and in order to save her life
bruce gives her a blood transfusion
which results in her turning into the
sensational she-hulk and jennifer is
able to maintain her personality and
skills when she is in the she-hulk form
in fact in the comics she often prefers
to remain in that form and you know what
uh good because
i'm all about it i'm i'm into tall green
girls you know what i'm saying uh yeah
that's on my uh bumble it's on my
christian mingle how's that going for
you
i uh i got two nuns to reply you've got
to sign up for green people meat i think
as well many people meet oh you're right
i need to sign up for a piece in a pod
yes
so we don't know why bruce has passed
his hulk abilities onto jennifer within
the mcu but from a very brief clip that
we've seen already it seems like he is
going to be mentoring her on how to
control the beast within but it is
possible that his 18 months in the gamma
lab showed him a way to make his blood
more stable for transfusions to you know
truly help those in need and you know
like i said before we do have amadeus
cho's mom in the mcu
very strong feeling that uh we're
probably gonna get an amadeus cho tv
show announced in the near future and
plus like it'd be great because like
marvel needs more asian heroes we need
more of them as much as we can shove it
to the mcu
let's just do it because i love
representation it's the best so yeah so
for amadeus cho to be introduced into
the mcu you know we're probably gonna
be via blood transfusion of some sort so
yeah i don't know i just feel like it
just makes sense and where there's
ambidex show there's uh there's hercules
and where there's hercules there's room
for bearded uh chubby white guys so
bring them up
you would make a fantastic hercules dude
but honestly like liam hemsworth if
you're watching marvel liam hemsworth
poor hercules make it happen absolutely
because why wouldn't you do that thor
his brother come on but there's one more
hulk family member that we should bring
up here and that is the red hulk when we
last saw him in you know black widow you
know dealing with the red room and red
hulk is a monstrous alter ego of our
very own thaddeus thunderbolt ross and
he's created when satellites were used
to de-power the hulk from a distance
during the comic events of world war
hulk which i think that i think was a
rumored that we're getting in the mcu
like world war hawk project which you
know thank god i really i really want to
see maestro very soon i really want to
see my show to be like the one that
causes world war hulk because let's do
it why not bring in the maestro yo
honestly bring in edward norton hulk as
the maestro let's do that because like
you could just have them come back for a
little bit and i'm sure you'd take the
money sorry i don't mean to do this
pitching stuff to marvel like hey listen
up and the gamma and cosmic rays
absorbed by these satellites were then
used to power a machine that turned
thaddeus ross into the red hulk and he
has very similar powers to the hulk with
the addition that he generates a lot of
heat she's a very hot hot man it's that
mustache really it it just really
complements the red skin oh yes but it's
interesting how red hulk was created
without any of the green hoax blood so
it's possible that whatever device we
see jennifer walters hooked up to in the
she-hulk eclipse could potentially be
transferring hulk rays into her um to
cause the transformation and if she'll's
creation does take place after the
events of endgame then it's possible
that all the knowledge that bruce gained
regarding the quantum realm and its
scientific properties could have shown
him a way to transfer the hulk powers
without any blood so who knows basically
in conclusion however it happens we're
excited to see the hulk family grow
within the mcu and of course again you
know there's there's amadeus cho i think
rick jones was a bomb for a little bit
that's our hulks what do you think tommy
how is the hulk going to make his cousin
into a she-hulk so here's how i uh uh
imagine we get to what we saw in the
trailer now we know jennifer walters is
uh an attorney at law so i think it's
gonna be a case of someone she put away
is going to exact revenge on her and
shoot her
and then
professor hulk smart hulk is going to
kind of have been toying with the idea
of using his blood to heal people but
he's going to have trouble extracting
the blood in his hulk form so he's going
to have to de-power himself down to
bruce banner blood and give him a banner
to walter's transfusion which will still
allow like he still has the hulk blood
inside him which will allow her
to
have the ability to go back and forth
and have the hulk blood inside of her
then and then he will then he will
mentor her into how to change back and
forth and then i think ultimately he'll
resettle back into his smart hulk form
would be my guess
[Music]
that's a really really good theory
because like yeah she is this
prosecuting attorney and she probably
has a lot of enemies she's probably put
a lot of bad people into prison and we
establish a new villain through that too
most likely you know we probably get
another exactly dylan for our uh our
rogues gallery of the mcu because you
know we we we need some more villains
coming down the pipe you know we're a
little bit yeah man
shortage not in spider-man spider-man
we've got a million villains but like oh
yeah i'm hearing the rumors on the vine
is that uh jim carrey will be modoc and
if that happens the world will change
because jim carrey would make a
fantastic modoc he is literally
oh my god a live action modoc which
obviously would still be cgi'd it would
be insane and if they are assembling an
italian intelligentsia team jim carrey
and val uh julie louis draft do you know
where we drive this together yeah comedy
gold like they're going to oh my god but
hey just so you guys know there's a
latest obsession shirt over at
newrockstarsmerch.com inspired by
hawkeye and it's a really really cool
design and you can grab one right now
and you can wear it while watching a
brand new episode of hawkeye featuring
haley steinfeld the greatest woman in
the world which is the best way to watch
a show and so you can find that shirt
and tons of other great merch options
inspired by loki spider-man and other
cool properties over at
newrockstarsmerch.com look at this
spider-man shirt no way huh and before
we dive into our bite size questions
next some words from the people that
help us bring big question to you people
like nabjitsu are you looking for a
healthier energy option to help you
power through that mid-afternoon sleepy
feeling that i get all the time because
i never get sleep my doctors are
concerned napjitsu has natural
time-released ingredients that keep you
energized for hours without the crash
nap jitsu's natural supplements were
made by people who know how it feels to
be tired and busy their patent-pending
formulas have natural ingredients like b
vitamins guarana and ginseng to give you
a boost of energy without the crash
later and each youtube product provides
brain boosting new tropics to unlock
steady energy right when you need it and
they keep you at your peak performance
all day long and navigate supplements
are packaged into small packets so you
can take them wherever and whenever you
might need an energy boost so whether
you need to experience deeper sleep or
unlock immediate lasting energy each
napji2 product is designed to help you
achieve your optimal performance
remember the smart rest more and the
whys rest better something i need to
remember myself so rest up and level up
with napjitsu for a limited time receive
thirty percent off your first purchase
when you go to napjitsu.com
big question so go to navjitsu.com
bigquestion for 30 off your first
purchase today that is n a p
j i t
s u not jitsu.com
big question let's talk finances a lot
of investment amps make it easy to start
trading my own personal app trader toms
allows you to buy stocks
bitcoins and nfts of my own designs i'll
draw you a smiley face and put it on the
internet for a million dollars but don't
use my terrible app we've been banned by
the fbi but just know
just because it's easy to do it doesn't
mean you know what you're doing god
knows i don't know what i'm doing i can
barely read that's what makes
wealthfront different they make it easy
to invest and they make it easy to get
smarter about investing okay after
answering just a couple questions
wallfront will build you a diversified
portfolio of low-cost index funds in a
matter of minutes you get those low-cost
index funds so the time it'll take you
to watch a new rockstar's 7-minute eric
vos easter egg video you're diversified
by then that's wonderful you can also
build your own portfolio with clean
energy funds crypto trusts cannabis tech
and hundreds of other investments
wealthfront offers a socially
responsible portfolio a mix of funds
built around human rights climate change
sustainability and diversity best of all
wealthfront is totally automated they do
all the trading all the rebalancing and
they even help you lower your tax bill
while you invest let's give thanks all
right a couple extra hundred bucks in
your bank account welfare is trusted
with over 27 billion in assets helping
nearly half a million people build their
wealth get your first five thousand
dollars managed for free for life by
going to wealthfront.com
bigquestion to start building your
wealth and get your first 5000 managed
for free for life go to wealthfront.com
big question that's
n t w-e-a-l-t-h-f-r-o-n-t-dot com slash
big question to start building your
wealth that's wealthfront.com
big question all right yes now it is
time for our bite size question tomato i
got a question for you how did makari
become deaf if the eternals are
essentially robots or was she created
like that and this is from crispy
chrissy on discord crispy chrissy i'm
looking at you thank you for always
supporting us on discord and just
holding it down thank you chrissy you're
wonderful in the recent film eternals
which is not just the title but also the
running time oh
oh oh you got em
here's a little bit of advice anytime
richard madden goes into his very sad
squiddish voice you can go take a piss
because
that's just a little spoiler-free review
of the movie for me in the recent film
eternals one of the crew of the heroes
we meet is makari she's delightful she's
the one with super speed as well as
having the distinction of being the
first deaf hero in the mcu in the comics
makari was originally a man who was not
deaf at some point in the 21st century
makari gets his mind wiped by sprite god
sprite why always effing things up yeah
sprite was really messed up at that
during that when she bribed everybody's
memories
in a series of events makaria becomes a
prophet for the dreaming celestial a.k.a
teemut tiamet uses makari to tell the
other eternals humans and deviants that
it's awake and is preparing for its
judgment which is what i do every
morning in my house i wake up and i go
i'm awake and i'm preparing for my
judgment
if i was ever a dad that's how i would
be like i have awoken time for judgment
children i just like to keep people on
their toes they're like what is he
judging oh my god what time did he go to
bed he was he was playing phil collins
in his room until 5 a.m and i kept
hearing cans opening it's just the
torzan soundtrack
for one's so small you can see him so
strong
all right it's also at this time that
makari rekindles his relationship with
cersei cute but then cersei finds out
from the dreaming celestial that the
horde is coming uh aka life destroying
alien insects not my favorite and that
makari must be protected at all costs
protect makari at all costs it's
thanksgiving season so life destroying
of alien insects are coming coming to
town well guess what this ain't game of
thrones but cersei still fails okay
makari is killed so cersei then
transmutes her own body into a perfect
replica of makari so the dreaming
celestial can keep doing its thing
tiamat speaks to the fulcrum earth is
spared the end right well wrong the
dreaming celestial winds up being killed
by an exterminator the death of tiamet
affects the newly resurrected makari
greatly since they were so closely
linked makari then transforms into a
woman and goes to great lakes to try and
revive the dreaming celestial she's
unsuccessful in that effort and the
amount of power she uses trying to reach
team it causes her to lose her ability
to speak in here she also loses her
telepathic abilities
but
that's the comics a question
that you know wasn't really what you
asked uh in the mcu we can only guess
why irishm designed makari to be deaf
maybe he's just evil maybe
he forgot to give her hearing i don't
know remember the wills and machinations
of the mighty celestials is simply
unknown to us mere mortals and how dare
you even question what they did god i'll
pray for you crispy because
i'll just pray hashem is not gonna be
happy about this hey don't pray too hard
or else you might lose your your your
hearing that actually happened to me
right when i made my first communion i
prayed so hard i went deaf for a couple
months uh we got another question yes
all right so here's another one it's
morbius an actual vampire and this is
from frogs unleashed on twitter unleash
the frogs yeah it's in the title oh my
god
next question no i'm just kidding
actually unleash frog man onto the mcu
please because i'm a huge frogman stan
jack black frog man unleash him we need
to see it you're in the croak crew all
right the crook well he is
often referred to as the living vampire
morbius is not a vampire in the
traditional supernatural capital d
dracula sense however dracula is a
character in marvel comics so there
certainly are true vampires that exist
in the marvel universe as we've seen in
the trailer for the upcoming sony verse
film morbius dr michael morbius has a
rare blood disease and in an effort to
cure that problem he winds up infusing
himself with the dna of a bat i heard
from leaks that uh he heard that he had
cooties from touching a girl so he
went through all this
bad dna trouble
the medical process for that is circle
circle dot dot oh he didn't hear about
that one now you've got a cootie shot
inject yourself with bat dna then go
have a really great day
so as i was saying he winds up infusing
himself with a little bit of bat dna and
this has some side effects and gives him
a lot of powers similar to a vampire
vampire adjacent abilities he has
superhuman strength speed agility and
stamina which is just another day in the
life of tom beck told he can also heal
quickly much like a real vampire he's
got fangs and claws bad ass he can glide
through the air over short distances not
fly not fly mind you but glide
he's a living vampire so he's not the
undead he has a beating heart which is
good but he also has a hunger for blood
which he must satiate
and while sunlight doesn't just dust him
away he is very sensitive to it but just
ask me and any of my fellow irish men
and women with red hair and pale white
skin and we're all a little scared of
the sun
so uh it doesn't make you a vampire it
just makes you unappealing aesthetically
he's also been known to turn people into
pseudo-vampires by draining them of all
their blood he has control over his
vampire babies and when they are killed
they turn to dust i mean come on
that's total vampire behavior what are
we doing here right yeah jack pick a
lane is he a vampire is he not i mean
listen the 70s were a crazy time as we
said and morbius was created in 1971 a
time when superhero stories were falling
out of fashion and horror comics were
all the rage the comics had to adapt and
that's why vampire asked morbius was
created other horror-based characters
that marvel introduced at the time
include blade man thing ghost rider and
moon knight and it's also around this
time that the aforementioned black law
shows up in the comics
dracula i want to suck your
blood so morbius is not a technical
vampire but he checks all the boxes that
a vampire would so he basically is one
so you know what get off my back
okay i tried my best for you if if if a
vitamin d deficiency is all you need to
be a vampire then i'm one too yeah
exactly if
if if an insatiable taste for human
blood really pale skin and and hesitancy
to go out in the sun or leave your house
entirely is what it takes to be a
vampire then you can just call me baby
drac cause i am
baby drac oh my god well that's it for
bite size questions you know what time
it is now baby boy it's time for the
books to screw
subscribe
scraps
what time with him if you had a hulk
instead of you what would be the
smallest pet peeve that would send you
into a hulking rage hmm
interesting because i am so easily
annoyed
[Laughter]
i would say
i guess this isn't really like a small
pet peeve but this is my huge pet peeve
and that is people who
purposely play dumb at the airport and
act as though it's the first time
they've ever traveled in order to not
comply to the like the rules of the
airport like people do that people every
person does that at the airport they
pack things in their bag that they
shouldn't then they go oh i didn't
realize you couldn't have a switchblade
in your carry-on
oh
wait i can't have a full bottle of smart
water going through the x-ray thing and
these are people that are in their 30s
40s and 50s so there's no i mean i
refuse to believe that they're all you
know i give an 80 year old man a pass if
he forgets the rules or is moving a
little slow we have to respect and take
care of our elders but if you're in the
range of 25 to 70 and you're walking
around the airport like it's a space
station you've never been on before i
don't believe you i think you're playing
i think you're playing the smartest game
in
in a free market world which is to play
dumb so that people give you what you
want but i'm talking like the the family
of five that rushes up when they call
boarding group one and then the ladies
like you guys are boarding group seven
and then by the time they do that nine
thousand other people line up i i could
talk about this for literally hours or
when the plane lands and we all know the
protocol is you de-plane in order of the
row that you're in and there's always
like seven people that just start
inching their way up the aisle because
they're impatient then it's not because
they have a flight to catch they just
don't comply to the social rules of
airplanes which are already stressful
enough anyway mt
if you had a hulk inside you what would
be the smallest
exactly that no i actually have never
been
on a plane in a long time like the last
time i was on a plane i was like six or
seven so i got there i don't have any
plane experience when you fly out to la
i'll fly to i'll fly to massachusetts
and and fly with you
yeah
tell me what not to do so i don't end up
being one of those lost people i'm like
mt stop trying to board the plane the
gate is closed
empty you can't go in the cockpit empty
you can't have a loaded gun on the plane
oh my god no that would be terrible one
of my biggest map is when people leave a
marvel movie when there are one to two
post credit scenes left and i'm like bro
i just wanted to hook up and be like sit
your ass down sit your ass down insanity
there's something coming all right and
like insanity i have a friend who's like
he's like you can just watch this on
youtube and i'm like
okay man well you can why would you do
that you can watch a lot of things on
youtube that are better seen you just
paid 25 to see this movie in l.a so
you're watching this like part of the
mcu are you not interested in what comes
next why are you leaving before like the
very end empty i could do a three-hour
show with you where i just answered this
question we could just go back and forth
which i think is just the family guy you
know what really drives my gears
i think we're just doing you know what
really grinds my gears people that tweet
things where they're bragging but then
they refer to themselves in a
disparaging way where they're like my
drunk ass with nine thousand dollars at
a casino last weekend but it's like
because they say my drunk ass we're
supposed to be like oh they're humble
it's like oh no all i hear is oh if i
was sober i would have won thirty
thousand now i i added a secondary gripe
to that because i'm having so much fun
complaining so if there was a box of
scraps award i would give it to you
because you got the best answer oh sam
right back at you right back at you all
right well that is it for this episode
of big question i of course want to
thank tommy bechtold for joining us i
missed you tommy please follow him on
twitter at tommy bechtol he's hilarious
he's a very great gentleman um and you
guys know tommy you guys are talking
more than me what am i saying um but you
can follow me master david on twitter if
you want to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] and wild theories but more
importantly please follow new rockstars
wherever you are on the internet
especially on youtube where you can hit
that notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and hey go to new
rockstarsmerch.com we got some cool ass
shirts man don't miss out don't get some
fomo man cause
hey man i get compliments on this all
the time so please pick up your swag at
new rockstarsmerch.com and hey if you
want to continue with the new rockstars
conversation our new rockstars discord
server is now open to the public and
we've made some sweet new channels
available to non-patrons so you can be
part of the broader community of new
rockstars fans on discord so if you're
over 18 and interested please search for
new rockstars discord server and join in
on the talk because we'd be talking
about nurtured all day long i need to
pop by one of these days and say hi
because they do love me some discord
convo anyway thank you guys so much for
watching we generally do love you please
stay safe and all right goodbye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]